the fact that matters is here
African-Americans have been technically
fully free Americans for only 53 years
53.
64 Civil Rights Act 65 Voting Rights Act
six day Fair Housing Act and you steal
we're dealing with
um being locked out when you when you
look at it look it comes the money if
you if you're not having a money
conversation in America you ain't having
a real conversation and so when you talk
about 400 plus years and you're only
being technically free 53 years and
you've been locked out consistently out
of corporate America I have actually met
nipple which is sad individuals who were
the first African-Americans to ever work
at major companies and they got there in
72 73 75 78. you're like what the heck
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]